foreign
Carrie joins us up next in Mobile
Alabama Carrie welcome to the show
hey good good afternoon
um I just wanted your
input as far as if you were in my
situation what you would you would do
I'm a single parent
um I'm in the middle of bankruptcy
and
I my car isn't working so my car's down
um and I was just served papers for
eviction
um I'm not
um I'm not currently working
a moment it's okay take your time Carrie
you're under it right now oh I've been
really prayed about calling and I
obviously didn't think I would get
through well you were supposed to get it
I'm the enemy because I'm Gonna Come On
Top I'm not going to get through this
yeah you are
um
I'm 51 I have two children and they're
it's a really long story but their
father is not involved how old how old
are the kids
um my youngest two are 11 and he's on
the Spectrum and then I have a
seven-year-old daughter okay
are you so I just are you able to work
um I have some
um
some uh issues physically
um but I have in the past
um but I'm home now because I had to
retain attorney for my son for an IEP
and I don't have to pay for that like it
it's free
um right to children with IDs so
um
so I'm in the process of that but if I
were to call you and uh an hour from now
and say hey I got a job for you
are you able to go do the job
assuming that it does not have all the
physical limitations but could you work
my car isn't working like it's been down
since before Christmas I had the
batteries I'm sorry I get it but can you
work or do you have child like who would
watch the kids that's what I'm trying to
say I mean we got to figure out you
don't so it's just me correct so you
couldn't work out of the house
theoretically right
you have no friends and family that
could watch the kids
no I do not okay so the only work that
you could do because we've got to get
some income in here right is is when
you're working remotely right
correct okay
because then you don't have to have
transportation so because we got to get
some income in here because you're
getting evicted you got a lot coming
your way yeah have you have you looked
into do you have a bankruptcy trustee
that you're working with
um I had I called him today and he
recommended
um filing chapter 13 because I have a
payment each month
and and the only reason I went that way
was to keep my vehicle
um but he suggested
um file in Chapter 13 and getting rid of
that
hundred thousand dollar debt and just
what's the hundred thousand dollar debt
um medical bills
um that's why I filed bankruptcy because
I was so overwhelmed with the payments
and I couldn't
I just couldn't do it now when you say
you're in the middle of bankruptcy how
far are you in the process
um I've already appeared in court okay
um and I missed like two payments and
the judge said that he wanted to see
like consistency as far as the payments
before it got
like totally was this while you had no
income
yes I mean I get SSI my son gets SSI so
I do have
is that even enough to cover your rent
um I live in uh subsidized housing it's
based off my income okay so how much is
your rent
currently it's
um ninety three dollars okay but you're
getting evicted from that housing
correct from being behind
um
just from being behind the 93 payment
and last month yes
that's what the paper say so are you
going to be able to get other subsidized
housing now
I
I've been in contact with them
the papers that they notified me to pay
the rent before the fifth and they did
not I mean I knew the rent was due by
the fifth I understand that
and I've always paid my bills or I've
made arrangements so I mean could you
fix this by saying all right I'm going
to come up with the 93 dollars for last
month and the 93 for this month and get
you back current or are they just saying
have you tried to negotiate with them
I have what'd they say I've been up
there and I've called them and he
referred me to the courthouse
okay I would work with your bankruptcy
trustee to figure out what your options
are what the laws are I don't want
anyone bullying you around with this but
you're A1 right now is food utilities
shelter and transportation that's it
that's all I want Carrie focused on and
making sure those kids have food on the
table and a roof over their heads and
whatever you have to do to do that even
if it's a work from home job or you
borrow a car are you part of a local
Church community in Mobile
um I am not okay I used to live there
there are so many great churches there
you've got to get plugged in with the
church let them know your situation uh
do you have any family or friends that
would be able to help
to cover your bills for a month
that would help me financially no
I'm I'm on my own okay well you you've
got to have Community here yeah you
can't do this alone right now and we've
your next step is to get that income up
as Ken said because we don't need a lot
to survive right now and we're just in
survival mode uh but that's what we need
to focus on is where are we going to
live next can we make sure we're not
evicted can we negotiate with them can
we scrape by 200 bucks can we get in
touch with a local Church community or a
Ministry out there that can help me
right now it's not can we it's we will
carry can I just speak to your mama
heart right now
yes I don't know
stronger human being on the planet than
a single mom
I just don't
you're a warrior you're a mama bear
would you let anybody harm those kiddos
absolutely not no
then I want you to harness that and I
know you have been through unbelievable
unbelievable storms
but you better summon your mama bear
right now
and if somebody came to harm those
babies you had died protecting them and
right now what is harming those babies
and harming you
is your financial instability you can
work you must work you go back to that
deadbeat government employee and say I'm
going to come up with 186 dollars you
find a way you fight you go get a remote
job you fight you go to a church and say
I'll come to church every Sunday morning
with these kids I need a battery in my
car you fight for those kids you fight
for you now
amen Well Carrie hang on the line we are
going to connect you with a financial
coach and we're going to pay for that
session so they can dig into the details
and walk with you through this we are
here for you please call us back